I love this guy who's joining us on the
show hey he's back for his 13th season
in the NFL didn't think he was gonna
play in the baker's dozen thought he was
calling it a career after 12 years with
the Carolina Panthers but he's back with
the Jets and man the Jets need him
certainly at center just in time Ryan
Khalil here on the show how you doing
brother
fantastic rich how are you I'm doing
fine where did the whole coming back to
play football thing come from
I just love bagels and delis they just I
couldn't find a good one in Manhattan
Beach yeah I know yeah it's better in
New York that way yeah it is mm-hmm so
it's really all about the bread is what
you're saying right that's it I mean
you've known me a long time I don't know
me a long time no I know it's just it's
tough to quit sometimes man it really is
isn't it it is it is and it's listen I I
mean I'll be the first to tell you how
lucky I've been to play as long as I
have and and I've got to be on some
incredible teams around some incredible
players and coaches I think for me you
know the biggest thing was just coming
off to tough injuries back to back and I
was coming up on my last year and
Carolina and I thought well maybe that's
this is the this is the sign maybe this
is the writing on the wall well and well
we'll make this last one and and we'll
soak it all in well we'll make sure that
you know we we really don't take
anything for granted and the surprising
thing that happen was is I felt great
throughout the whole season and I and I
felt real healthy and and I felt like my
old self and so I still kind of felt the
holdin to kind of call it quits and sold
the house and moved the family back to
California which was always the plan for
us and I guess was having a hard time
turning the page and so I started
working out and trained the only way I
know how to which is getting ready for
football season I thought maybe that
would be therapeutic and that just made
it worse
so anybody trying to turn the page I
recommend don't doing that just go ahead
and do the Joe Thomas Jordan grouse
routine and just drill down as quickly
as you can so yeah so and then
I just I was feeling even better doing
that and you know running out on the
Strand shirt off obviously which wasn't
turning to many heads but but but yeah
so I called my agent Tom Khan and I just
said hey I said you know I don't I don't
quite think I'm done yet so I said I'm
gonna keep training and working out and
I said just kind of keep your ears open
and and if something exciting sort of
pops up if the right opportunity pops up
let's let's talk about it and so I guess
the plan for me was I was just kind of
kind of stay in shape and then if if
nothing came up and the season went by
and then that would be sort of the final
stamp on it and fortunately for me I got
a call saying hey there's some interest
in the center for New York and and we
started talking about it and then you
know obviously you're snapping it to has
something to do with with with all the
excitement but I want to get to that in
a second Ron khalil and just delve a
little bit more cuz again you're a guy
with a great head on your shoulders and
you're a thinker and you and you and
your ruminate and you you try and put
your finger on things before you make a
maneuver what exactly about the game was
tough to quit do you think um I just
think you know you you know you play
along too most of us have been playing
since we were kids I started when I was
eight years old and you just have this
structure and every year it's it's you
know you're moving up to another level
and you don't really think long-term I
don't think I mean I just I try at least
for myself I've tried to stay in the
moment most of my career and and stay in
the day and then stay in the week and
then in the season and then you try to
reboot and and reset re-energize during
the offseason to get ready for another
one so I you know it just I think making
it official moving back to California it
just being so funny you know so
definitive that that was it but that was
that was the end was the first time I
got to
kind of be in a place where I got to
reflect on that and I think I just had
these feelings of regret or I might have
regret if I sort of didn't if I didn't
play all the way through whatever
potentials whatever potential I had left
you know I just it's such a small window
and once it's done it's done forever
that door shut so I think something
about that is just being as long as I am
and knowing that you know it's not it's
still not gonna be that much longer if I
if I still have some left
having that regret of leaving some on
the table I just I just I had a hard
time moving on from that and then and
then you know the things that everybody
always talks about the locker room
you know Sunday's not training camp
which I timed it out perfectly you're a
savvy veteran Ryan yours that's not
forget you're a savvy veteran at first
and foremost so so I think most guys
won't won't miss that but yeah so I just
think you know for me just knowing that
that was gonna that I wasn't gonna be
able to do that ever again I just I had
a hard time moving on from all that
stuff
Ryan khalil Jets Center here on the Rich
Eisen show okay and then it's USC puts
the hands on the ball to start the play
and then USC touches the ball with Sam
Darnell Thomas Lee you saw what the kid
did here in Southern California
collegiate Lee since you pay attention
to the program now that you got a first
close-up look over the last week what
about Sam Donald Eve's out at you
Ryan Khalil I think just how much of a
pro he is just being in year two and you
can tell this is a kid that that cares
and he understands how to study what he
what he needs to study and then just
ability wise I mean he's just he's he he
has a incredible football awareness and
so I think there's there's a ton of
exciting upside for him you know
hopefully I can come in and and help
take some of the stuff off his plate so
he
can continue to advance some of his
other sort of mental aspects and things
that he he has to focus on in the
secondary in the passing game so that
that's that's one of the many aspects
about the kid that I really like
obviously the football player but but
even as a guy he's he's just an
incredible prohees a good teammate you
can tell just being in year two I mean
that's a tough thing to do to be in year
two and a sort of command that kind of
respect around the locker room just in a
short time I've been here you can tell
how much the guys really respond to him
and that's what you want in a Corvette
engage says he could throw the piss out
of the ball Ryan if anybody knows what's
inside the ball clearly you would know
and whether he can throw that out of it
what do you think yeah I think he can I
mean obviously like you said I I watched
them when he was in us when he was at FC
and and and obviously many people paid
attention to him last year when he came
in there and and he's uh he's he's
definitely a guy that people need to
watch and and and I'll you know I'm
excited for the opportunity to be able
to help him any way I can
yeah and and just again just to be clear
there is no piss in the ball right Ryan
correct no I don't not that I recall no
I've been away a long time but I'm yeah
yes in terms of in terms of returning to
the game there still is no piss in the
ball right there might be I don't know
okay I you know well you wouldn't know
because it's out of the ball thanks to
Sam Donald so you wouldn't know it is is
gates the first head coach you've ever
seen crack open uh a smell of salt
before the game like we saw last night
Ron did you see that last yeah yeah I
did I did Richard yeah I didn't want to
answer first second I see the first one
I think he's the first one I've seen I
don't know maybe the cameras caught it
yeah he no not not the first time I've
seen a head coach with it with the
smelling salts no but
first time I've seen a go viral for sure
yeah that's for sure yeah okay
is it are you are you saying Rivero used
to snap don't you say I can either
confirm nor deny everybody the cagey
Ryan Khalil you're on the Rich Eisen
show so are you are you putting your
film production career on hold are you
still doing any stuff are we gonna see
more videos from you throughout the
season what look tell me what to expect
uh well that's yeah that's never on hold
the grind never stops you know that rich
you know that I do know that yep
okay uh I'm a multitasker I can do
multiple things well didn't you used it
right I can reach a shade and and do
some script coverage okay yeah you you
used to DM Brockman right origami right
didn't you used to yeah I'm waiting for
the paper plane origami DMS this year
Yeah right
oh is that well they only did that
because you you said we were paper
tigers that you started that crack la
broadcasting Center staff has shown you
that the paper Bengal that you you diem
dafter the Panthers took care of the
Bengals Thanksgiving it was a turkey
don't worry 20 of time to take shots at
you got a patriot fan across the way so
did you settle in Jersey or is that
where you're gonna you're gonna be out
there or you going to New York where you
going wrong did you figure out oh I'm
gonna I'm I'm too old to go live in New
York rich I'm gonna be right here right
outside the facility okay within walking
distance okay you're just a pro you're
just gonna win some football games levy
on bail that must be a pleasure too
right yeah yeah yeah he's uh he's a he's
a funny character man I got to I've got
to hang out with him last couple days
and I can tell he's it and uh he's it
tend to get going okay maybe you know
he's got a
a career going maybe you should make the
music videos for him well I actually
asked and he'll he'll confirm this I
asked him yesterday if he put me out of
track okay and he well he's a little
hesitant he doesn't know me like like
you know me rich so you might need to
put in a word for me or maybe I gotta
send him in a mixtape or something I
don't know well I mean obviously Ryan
you know levian isn't just doing this as
a hobby says I mean he's that you need
to prove yourself I guess to him if I do
know that you would crush it given the
opportunity I don't understand
quite honestly run you know I'll vouch
I'll vouch by the way you'd be the first
person I ever vote for rapping that's
for sure I don't know if I'm the guy but
I do have an in with Lev I'll do it for
you Ryan no I appreciate it I always
catch I appreciate it hey congrats on on
following your gut man and getting a
hell of a spot too I mean this is a
great opportunity this is terrific I'm
thrilled for your brother know I'm
excited a lot of people around here very
excited about me coming here a little
too excited so I'm trying to walk around
tamper the expectations just a little
bit you know give myself a little room
for error here
right you know ya know I got you but
enjoy the snaps that you get when you
how many you're gonna get in pre-season
do you think I can't tell you that coach
said I can't I can't talk about okay
okay okay
changes the whole game plan for another
team and preseason understand know what
they're not just my bad my bad my bad
alright thanks for the call Ryan take
care everybody take your chat soon you
got it that's rankling for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app